er hat alles lust auf eine schöne runde
billige bahn bashing witze na ja
wirklich die blöde witze schreiben sich
quasi von selber hier bahn chef lutz hat
einen brandbrief zum zustand der bahn
geschrieben
der kam aber drei tage zu spät an weil
er mit einem pc verschenkt wurde
abu dhabi oder hier einen habe ich noch
fragt er schaffen eine junge mutter
haben sie denn auch ein ticket für ihr
kind nie sagt die mutter als jene zu
gestiegen bin war ich ja noch schwanger
prinzip ist klar geworden
es ist zu billig ja es ist zu billig und
der bahnchef herr lutz will jetzt sagt
er das ruder rumreißen
das fürchte ich wird aber nicht einfach
denn das mit den verspätungen ist im
ersten halbjahr 2008 10 sogar noch
schlimmer geworden nur noch 77 prozent
aller züge im fernverkehr kamen ungefähr
zum geplanten zeitpunkt an 80 prozent
war das ziel
mittlerweile gibt es an allen deutschen
bahnhöfen so konfetti kanonen wenn ein
ic x pünktlich kommt es liegt natürlich
auch an bis zu 800 baustellen täglich
und daran dass die bahn immer noch auf
verschleiß fährt die infrastruktur
verrottet schneller als er repariert
werden kann
unsere große mächte dass im jahr 2030
doppelt so viele menschen zug fahren wir
heute will dafür aber auf keinen fall
mehr geld ausgeben es geht irgendwie
nicht zusammen
trotzdem muss der kunde natürlich nur
über die bahn
[Applaus]
wir waren selten bahn aber ich habe es
noch nicht an den letzten jahren dass
ein us präsident bush preise wie gut das
hängt jetzt aber ganz stark davon ab in
welchem hofmann gehen also meinem hof
zum beispiel ist auch egal
tatsache ist 2017 sind 140.000 züge
komplett ausgefallen
140.000 dh die bahn muss tatsächlich
besser werden was aber nicht leicht ist
wenn man rund 20 milliarden euro
schulden hat trotzdem sollten wir
irgendwie auch froh sein dass
deutschland noch so ein tolles
schienennetz hat und jede menge
bekennende bahnfans die olaf schubert
[Applaus]
jedoch scheint nicht mehr so schubert
oder jetzt fährt wirklich sehr viel bahn
was ist dein fazit als bahnkunde ich
fahre viel beifahrer sehr viel bahn gibt
ja ich muss ja auch irgendwie zum
flughafen kommen und insgesamt es wird
viel geschimpft aber bahnfahren ist ein
luxus die bahn es sagt ja auch es ist
deine zeit und durch diese ganzen mit
verspätung hat man im endeffekt mehr
zeit als ein liebes aber es ist ein
prima service was können wir denn machen
gegen die verspätung los von albanisch
studien beweisen es also nicht so viele
karten sehen ist ja entfernung ist weg
durch zeit mal tempo plus technische
störung ja und natürlich fordere ich
auch von kunden ein bisschen mehr
elastizität ich meine muss man jetzt
wirklich immer punkt 17 uhr 45 in
gütersloh ankommen ich meine in
gütersloh erreicht auch wenn man gar
nicht ankommen es fahren züge zwischen
gera und gütersloh oder frage ich mich
warum es wäre effizienter wenn man eine
von beiden städten schließt aber bei der
reiseplanung nicht mehr ganz so
möglichkeit fanatisch da geht es nicht
um minute genau hier deutlich meine dass
man eben ein bisschen puffer einplanen
dass man eben sagt also nicht ich muss
jetzt hier sitzen nur 13 in hamburg
sondern eher sagen wir mal in der woche
irgendwo im norden
also weniger leistungsdruck mehr sondern
sonne walldorf bahnen ja jetzt ist ja
ihr sind das immer mehr flix busse und
auch riesen laster die ohnehin vollen
straßen verstopfen was muss passieren um
die schiene wieder attraktiver zu machen
ich finde es gut ist dass ältere
verkehrsteilnehmer werden ja jetzt von
der bahn per taxi zum bahnhof gebracht
aber da frage ich mich warum der umweg
bahnhof und nicht direkt zum ziel
also ich finde die bahn muss die schiene
berichten es ist so wie die proletarier
ihre ketten abgerufen haben vor 200
jahren
so muss die summe ist die bahn liegt die
schiene von sich werfen ich meine die
schiene wurde vor 200 jahren erfunden
damit die lokführer nicht verfahren
heute gibt's navi so also die bahn
gehörte nicht in die luft im
einundzwanzigsten jahrhunderts lag bei
der achterbahn geht es ja auch und
zuzüglich musste der service insgesamt
irgendwie verbessert werden da gibt es
so viele ideen was weiß ich dass am
wochenende die fußball-fans eben auch
mal in der ersten klasse randalieren
dürfen oder dass man die nichtraucher
abteile wieder einführt für welche die
unbedingt eine bulette essen müssen was
weiß ich und natürlich marketing also
dass man die eigenen probleme bisschen
offensiv positiver darstellt
die slogans liegen ja alle schon rum das
war hier der tag geht die baden kommt
vielleicht weiß ich jetzt mal wieder
länger dauert deutsche bahn der weg ist
das ziel also irgend sowas unpünktlich
aber teuer schlecht es muss nicht mehr
nicht sein ich meine also gehen wir
eigentlich hin
unser nächster halt chemnitz bitte nicht
aussteigen sechs dorfchemnitz fließen
tränen
ach du scheiße ohne schuhe immer hinter
sich
[Applaus]
[Musik]